yesterday was the LA Marathon yeah the
only time of year you see someone
running in the streets of Los Angeles
when it's not the end of a car chase
[Applause]
that's my favorite part of any car chase
yeah they get rammed by eight police car
as they get out and start running
helicopters nets nope I'm gonna run my
run
anyone here running the marathon did you
really how you feel today ah well what a
nice way to recuperate like I want to go
someplace restful and quiet I'll go to
Conan let's say they had a a st.
Patrick's Day parade in Boston yesterday
a special one for the first time ever
gay people were allowed to march in
Boston's st. Patrick's Day parade and
it's a lot of guys in Boston feared it
turned everyone wicked gay it just did a
lot of guys like I knew what happened
this is kind of strange everyone's
starting to a lot of Republicans are in
New Hampshire and they're campaigning in
in New Hampshire Tea Party candidate and
presidential hopeful Ted Cruz had to
comfort a little girl who got scared
during his campaign speech she got
spirit yeah part of the little girl felt
much better after Cruz reassured her he
doesn't have a chance in hell so
[Music]
people are still angry about the
threatening letter written by a
Republican congressman to Iran yes
also not helping was the Republicans
started the letter dear Iran or Iraq we
can never keep you two straight
speaking of Foreign Affairs Vladimir
Putin appeared in public for the first
time after a mysterious 10-day absence
ten days he was gone
yeah Putin said it took me that long to
recover from the finale of The Bachelor
[Applause]
he / baton is crazy I didn't know that
someone had to tell me Saturday was 314
or as it's otherwise known international
Pi Day yeah where the world celebrates
the mathematical concept of pi yes
Americans said you lost me at math but
you got me back at Pi
in fact who here actually thought I was
talking about the pie you eat when I
said that I knew there were a couple of
times like Friday and then when I said
mathematical concept of pie I saw it I
just saw oh this is crazy it's being
reported that because of the birth of
his baby daughter because of the birth
of his baby daughter Chris Brown has
decided to stop calling women hoes in
his music he said he's going to go with
the more traditional term
[Applause]
you